est ce que vous connaissez étincelles
depuis quelques mois avec l'école
polytechnique fédérale de lausanne a
fait que ces informatiques et de
communication en particulier je fais des
vidéos qui expliquent l'informatique de
façon simple très abordable buts ses
rangs d'être sainz fort vers yole comme
la chaîne étaient appelés à une époque
sur l'informatique des trucs très
instructif avec notamment des trucs
offre explicatif un peu classique ya
également des vidéos d'ateliers ou
comment on a fabriqué un le plus grand
réseau artificielle capable à peu près
d'apprentissage au monde avec des doigts
et puis aussi des vidéos au palais de la
découverte avec emilien cornillon ou je
me bats contre des artisans certifie
ciel en carton ou encore des activités
de blocs chaîne humaine faite en classe
où vous invite à aller voir et
vous donner envie voici quelques
extraits moi je préfère le zoo de
malheur mais j'avais dit que la rétro
provocation ce sera difficile
en l'occurrence n'ya plus que la route
donc du coup lille va jouer sous poule a
et donc elle va venir manger
l'option blanc tiens prends toi sale et
7 apprendra à défier unia en fait il y a
même tout une discipline de recherche
appelé l'algorithmique qui consiste à
déterminer quels problèmes peuvent être
résolus en suivant quelles instructions
donc on va se retrouver avec
nas donc tu as perdu face à un groupe de
boîtes en carton et de perdre petit à
machine sait déjà quelle autre machine
sur internet et responsable du domaine
au pfl point ch elle peut la contacter
directement
il n'y a pas d histoire comme quoi des
vpn permettent d'éviter cela voir
pendant vos
records du monde
c'est à dire que en fait dans cette
boîte là quoi qu'il arrive
l'ia va perdre
c'est à dire qu'en fait dans cette boîte
là quoi qu'il arrive mieux à perdre
lieve à perdre hier à pékin a déclaré
forfait du coup ça fait une victoire
pour le ps yes yes j'ai réduit au
forfait
devra pourvoir